so you clean a bunch of PC games on your
MacBook Air yeah look at this man it's
running on my MacBook Air Assassin's
Creed Odyssey yeah and native resolution
high graphics settings about 60 FPS it's
a good job moving the camera around but
the character okay okay sure so shadow
is been around for what a couple years
now it's like a cloud service where you
rent out essentially a server that's in
the cloud and you treat it like it's a
Windows PC and you can just install
steam on it yes all your games from
there so it's not like a subscription
service to games you're just renting a
PC and the guest and you can have full
control over it you can access it either
through any device that can run it low
if it has Windows or Mac OS even iOS and
Android the shadow app will work on it
which gives you access to the PC that's
located remotely you can also buy the
set-top box if you don't have any other
device and because it yeah shadow ghost
if you want to put in like a like a TV
home theater setup yeah well speaking of
which we've also read reports that
shadow should work on any Android
enabled TV as well I'm not an Apple TV
it can get a little complicated with
other devices but I mean the fact that
you can access like a gaming PC as long
as you have a decent internet connection
is Right it's pretty dope it's
convenient but like with any other
streaming service where cloud-based
gaming there are gonna be some hiccups I
guess or some concerns about like input
lag video compression and just overall
like smoothness of your video feed yeah
because you're you're getting video feed
you're not actually controlling like a
local it's not local Hardware of course
yeah and streaming's been around for a
while but it's just kind of really
picking up steam now honestly like it
only seems like it's sort of becoming a
bigger thing for a lot of places like
Google for example had you know their
Assassin's Creed Odyssey demo like their
project stream demo a couple months back
and that worked pretty well I think a
lot of us
you know pretty surprised with how good
that was and now we know that they're
gonna be saying some stuff at GDC
presumably about whatever that was it is
the Game Developers Conference after all
yeah and Microsoft has also been you
know talking about bringing like gamepad
stuff to switch was just wild and we've
seen other cloud streaming games on
switch like Resident Evil 7 in Japan
which is just all to say that like scrim
he's been around for a while but like
maybe now is the time yeah maybe the
infrastructure is there but also maybe
the markets there as well because the
thing is you know you have to rely on an
internet connection that's that is the
only real like requirement that's going
to dictate how well the actual stream is
gonna how well your games are gonna run
so I think that you know it's there at
home I was playing the chat shadow off
of a wireless connection and for the
most part like I was playing anthem was
playing Metro I was playing a Apex
legends now those other games where it's
not really competitive base it was
perfectly fine for that I was able to
play smoothly there are some hitches
there but it doesn't really affect the
moment-to-moment gameplay sure the thing
is like my concern is like with
competitive games soul is playing at GFX
legends even on a wireless connection
there were some hitches every now and
then you know you wouldn't think that
much of it if you're playing Assassin's
Creed right but I also don't think that
like streaming is being pitched is like
this will totally replace your gaming
stripe right like it's really just about
like look maybe you haven't had the
ability to play these games before we'll
give you the chance to do that and yeah
not everything's gonna be perfect right
away let alone technically like certain
games just you know they require such
like pinpoint millisecond accuracy you
know to determine who's the winner is
the loser yeah I don't think they're
really making claims about that so I
don't know like I'm really curious about
it just from a convenience perspective
like dude you've got four GPUs in your
desk oh so much a PlayStation 4 2 pcs
you don't need to stream this stuff I
really don't
but how would this fit in to some what
do you know attitude to lives like ours
where we have access to all these things
yeah at home I have a much more limited
space so anyone who does have limited
space or doesn't really want to worry
about having like a like a bulky piece
of hardware in their setup or whatever
but they do have a good internet
connection like this will work and you
know I don't know like we've seen what
PlayStation now yeah okay so yeah
Internet hasn't changed that much in the
last like years yeah yeah but there's
like I think a big difference between
like who is serving you this stuff from
from where you know we're into the class
it's like look Microsoft has their as
your server Network Amazon has their Web
Services what is PlayStation leveraging
I don't know but a lot of stuff I tried
there like never really worked yeah I
mean there's a reason why on live field
yeah also like the early days of PS now
was not great but I've you know over
time like companies figure out how to do
these kinds of things and when you have
big names like Google doing project
stream putting that out with Assassin's
Creed earlier last year that was like a
like a very good test case like oh no no
we figured out how to do this stuff in a
way that's almost identical to playing
traditionally on a console or PC and
then you know with Microsoft doing their
cloud stuff like they've introduced it
with crackdown 3 kind of test the waters
but I really feel like they're gonna
make some big moves and Google is gonna
have a make big moves at GDC like you
mentioned so it's a it's a matter of
them figuring out how to deliver this
stuff and I think like also shadows
figure out a way to do it but that's
just like for them I mean it's not just
mirroring a PC of course in that sense
but that is what they're doing so it's
all these companies kind of like figure
out ways to deliver this stuff in a way
that makes sense
and well that's enticing as well right
like the consumer has to want this yeah
and maybe like they can say well sure
yeah it'd be great if this worked
exactly as it says it would but I don't
believe it like they're gonna have to
give you ample like a way to like really
test this you know give away free games
or give away a trial period yeah there's
always gonna be a like a growth period
or a period of where you have to like
work out the the pains of an early
service or an early adoption of a new
kind of technology so yeah if we're
gonna see game pass on switch or
something or gonna be able to play xbox
games stream from the cloud to your
switch there's gonna be have to be test
cases that mean like assume that's also
why
Google put out Assassin's Creed Odyssey
essentially for free if you got into
their project stream beta if these are
the early showings of cloud-based gaming
it's quite impressive I would say like
as someone who's very plays a lot of
csgo who plays a lot of fighting games
you know of course it's not there for
those kinds of things but you know it's
closer than it's ever been
nvidia like two or three years ago
brought me to their headquarters and
they had PR balrog there and they're
like you're gonna play Street Fighter
next to pure Arab era
using our game streaming service the one
that is videos training oh yeah and it
was like kind of working but even he was
like in front of them like yeah I would
never choose to play this way so yeah I
mean it'll take a long time to get there
but I think it probably will get there I
have to imagine like assuming the world
doesn't end you know technology will
continue to improve and and that will
happen
[Music]
other thing too is that since this is
cloud-based streaming you're gonna be
using up a lot of data I don't know the
exact numbers but I mean that is
something to think about is that you
know since you're constantly getting
video stream that's just data that's
being eaten up now when you use like a
Netflix and watch a movie like for an
hour or two hours worth of like video
that's that that's data you're using
within that finite amount of time but if
you had just have this like running in
the background if you don't forget like
if you forget to shut it off at any time
like you're just constantly using up
data so that'll be a problem in other
you know regions that have data caps or
maybe their infrastructure isn't as good
as ours
these companies are thinking about that
of course so I don't think that they're
necessarily targeting those markets it's
like it's it goes back to what you said
this isn't gonna be necessarily be for
an everyone it's not gonna replace
entirely replace no yeah the thing well
when you've got Microsoft and Google you
know huge companies that speak to
everyone saying we've got this thing
everyone's gonna want to be a part of it
it'll be interesting to see like how
they deal with the inevitable stumbles
that will happen if people it's got to
start somewhere if I got moved to this
and what another thing too is that maybe
this isn't matter as much to other
people but you when you stream video
feed you're not using again you're not
using a local hardware so you're not
consuming like electricity you're not
stressing out your laptop like for
example here like on my macbook air this
is as if I was watching a Netflix video
so no fans are spinning up the laptops
not getting hot and I'm not using as
much battery like I don't even have this
being charged and it's not like in low
power mode so about losing frames or
getting skips because of that since it's
all based on my internet connection so
that's another thing to think about it's
just like diverting all those resources
to your internet connection but you know
I don't know what Internet
infrastructure is gonna look like in the
future but if it improved
and like data caps aren't as much of an
issue for other regions who's to say
this might even take off first and like
you know other countries right have more
denser populations with stronger
internet yeah infrastructure is built in
the u.s. is a tough nut to crack though
it's just a whole big chunks of the
country that are just sort of sort of
left in the [ __ ] yeah
[Music]